hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll a lot of people i think when
they think about math when they hear the
words math and doing math they think of
what a mathematician would call
calculating right performing some
calculation whether it's something
simple like calculating the tip on a
restaurant bill something maybe more
complicated like calculating the orbits
of planets and stars and galaxies and so
forth but that's actually very very
little of what professional
mathematicians do we use math in that
way but professional mathematicians are
engineers of concepts they invent new
kinds of concepts they put them together
to prove theorems and they draw
connections between concepts that you
might not have known about before so
today's guest tai denae bradley works at
a very interesting intersection of
algebra and information
algebra being in the mathematician sense
a kind of study of structures in
mathematical objects so ways you can
multiply things together uh ways you can
combine things and also ways you can
take things apart that relate to each
other and then build them back into the
original whole
and then information in the sense of
what relates to what what do you know
about one thing by learning about
another thing so here's an example that
you might not think of as originally
mathematics but that is absolutely
closely related to this stew of algebra
information
language the language you're hearing
right now the set of words that you're
listening to has a structure in it right
because when certain words pop up other
words are more likely to pop up right
next to them and of course you can take
a completely mindless approach to
understanding this you can just dump it
all in a computer right dump a huge text
in a computer and ask what are the
statistics of this what words appear
next to what other words but you can
also think like a mathematician you can
say well why is it like that what are
the structures underlying this kind of
thing and it's kind of an interesting
mathematical move to introduce the idea
of statistics and probability into this
kind of study because
certain words in language appear next to
each other more frequently but it's not
absolute right it's sort of a relative
connection between these things and
that's not natural always for
mathematicians to study so tied in a
really works at this fascinating
confluence of algebra information
statistics and that has led her to think
about one of my favorite topics which is
entropy so we talk in this uh podcast
about
well let me let me tell you ahead of
time it's going to sound simpler than it
is she really is really very good at
explaining things in a way that kind of
don't scare you in terms of mathematical
formalism and jargon and all that stuff
but you can read the papers behind it
they're all real math papers that
involve all the formalism and jargon
that you want but we're going to be
talking about category and topology and
probability theory and a little bit of
emergence and entropy and other things
that i'm very interested in for those of
you who like this kind of thing i'll
also encourage you to check out tai
dinet has a website called mathema
except instead of the e in ema it's a
three so that's math3ma
where she does a series of very nice
expository blog posts videos things like
that really a wonderful ability to make
these very high-powered mathematical
concepts seem a little bit less
intimidating than they should be so with
that let's go
[Music]
hi janae bradley welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you sean for
having me it's great to be here so we've
agreed this is going to be a challenge
you know we're bringing you on here
because
uh
you have a certain genius for explaining
these difficult things uh but but that's
okay and it's actually very good for me
because i do a lot of work in trying to
explain difficult concept and physics to
people and it's always good to be
humbled a little bit when i'm reading
your paper i'm like this is what it's
like for other people when they read my
papers and i don't know what any of the
words mean so let's just start with some
some
sort of setting the stage kind of stuff
like a big part of your work involves
algebra algebra and statistics was was
right there in the title of your thesis
so what do you mean when you use the
word algebra it's probably not like
solving quadratic equations
that's right that's right so when i say
the word algebra i
mean it
in a less
technical
potentially scary sense that folks might
think okay
so in in the title of my thesis
at the interface of algebra and
statistics i really just meant
algebra and the basic sense of
sticking things together
so you know you mentioned quadratic
equation quadratic you know that makes
us think of x squared or something i
have two numbers and i you know one
number i multiply it by itself or i have
two things
and i can multiply them and get a third
thing you know that's of the same flavor
or the same type as the two that i
started with maybe there's maybe they're
numbers but
you know as one progresses in math you
you learn that you can multiply things
that aren't numbers and you can make
sense where it gets hairy yes i know
yeah
so i just meant when i say algebra there
i just mean in the sense that i have you
know things and i want to have some
notion of multiplication or you know
concatenation or some type of way that i
can combine these things to get
something larger so very basic
not not really technical quite yet
that's what i mean great so we're
composing things together but just to
put a little meat on those bones here
what are some of these things so if i
multiply two numbers together that's an
algebraic kind of thing or two variables
what are other kinds of things that i
can combine together yeah so in the
context of my thesis the things that i'm
i'm really
having in the back of my mind are words
or expressions in a language in a
natural language actually okay
so so
think for a second about something like
um
i guess the example i often give is
red
is a word yep there you go and fire
truck
is a word
and now i want to combine them so that i
get a new expression you know in the
english language
so i'm going to define a multiplication
but let's call it stick those things
together red
fire truck stick them together you get
red fire truck or if i want to be more
precise i just really mean concatenation
okay
so so that's one example that maybe you
you might not think of um it's not
doesn't feel like math you know we learn
about red firetrucks when we're i don't
know two years old looking through
picture books um but i'm sort of
secretly or not so
secretly suggesting that there's
algebraic structure even in something
like language okay but this is good
because
when i take red and fire truck and
concatenate them i get a phrase rather
than a single word so part of the
algebraic
uh magic is that when we do this
generalization of multiplying we need
not get the same kind of thing that we
started with that's right that's right
so you may
that's exactly right so then you kind of
ask how do you keep track of that you
know you sort of feel that not only do
you have these things called words
but then there's other things called
expressions which are like multiple
words and maybe you want to keep keep
track of those you know maybe you have
all english expressions of length one
that's what we we call words you know
dog
cat
breakfast oh that's a compound word okay
anyway but then that you know then you
have you have like the set of all
english words of length too you know red
fire truck hot dog tasty breakfast blah
blah blah and then you can look at those
of length three and then maybe you might
want to say you know how how
how does the algebraic structure pair
well with the fact that i have different
lengths involved
but there are actually tools in algebra
that that deal with that um but maybe i
don't want to throw in technical words
so quickly at the beginning but i'll
just say yes this already gives gives a
mathematician you know you're getting
excited already yes there's lots of
things that we can think about and math
has lots of answers
and and just to be clear this example of
concatenating words this is not just a
metaphor this you're saying this really
is something we can think of as an
algebra yes that's right
go ahead yeah i'll say um in case there
are mathematicians listening you know
and we say n algebra there is a very
very specific you know strict definition
in the sense of abstract algebra um one
can make sense of that true
but to be more precise i might mean
something like
um am i allowed to use technical
technical words i might say something
like
ammanoid really
that's just a like a gentler
you know um friendlier atmosphere in
which you can talk about multiplying
things together maybe an algebra in the
technical sense and math kind of comes
with some extra stuff but but the basic
mathematical framework where you have a
bunch of things you know like a set or a
bag of marbles or a bag of words and you
want to have a notion of
multiplying them together in some sense
um something like that we'd call that a
monoi so that's kind of what i mean yeah
i think that going forward we're allowed
to talk about the technical terms
because we want to be able to give the
listeners some takeaways like if they
ever see this somewhere else
we were talking about infinity group
words with emily real before so you know
we shouldn't we shouldn't feel bad about
it
no problem
um i mean it is in the first few minutes
but okay we're it's all going to be
downhill from here so
does does this way of thinking about
language uh let us take into account the
fact that for example
certain
concatenations of words make sentences
and certain other ones don't can we can
we put the rules of grammar into our uh
monoid right right so you'd like you'd
like something else um that's exactly
right there's this observation that
algebraic structure is there
but it's not really everything it's not
really all that there is to language
because you make this observation not
everything goes together you know you
can't multiply everything and get
something that's legal you know or
something that makes sense
um
uh so now some folks might think well
maybe the additional structure you need
is some type of grammar or syntax or
something
but in my thesis um
there's a perspective
uh that's taken that is actually there
are statistics in language
um because right red fire truck is
something that maybe appears quite
frequently in the in the english
language and it might appear more
frequently than um the other example i
like to give is red idea you know i
did i wake up this morning and have a
red idea like what does that even mean
that's not a thing that people say
um so
um there's actually an observation you
can make or not an observation but maybe
a hypothesis or something you might want
to
stand firm on and that is that
statistics actually can maybe serve as a
proxy for grammar i see so that is the
extra bit of mathematical structure
that's missing from language so there's
algebra but then what else like how do
you know what really goes together and
what's valid in your in your language
yeah you need to know that you know in
english at least adjectives precede
nouns you know
read fire truck but maybe in a different
language it's reversed or something like
that but how do you know well you can
kind of look at the the landscape look
at what's out there what has every human
said you know from the dawn of time in
english
and you can just you know count the
number of times that red firetruck has
appeared and you can see that that that
number is bigger than the number of
times red ideas appeared and maybe the
totality of that algebraic structure
what goes with what
together with the statistics that you
observe about it
tell you um like what's the deal with
your language what are valid expressions
in your language and what's not and one
way to see that you can look at the
statistics or what has been said so it's
it it is
already an interesting kind of shift of
perspective um to how mathematicians
think because people on the street would
say well you know grammar is a set of
rules for
these words work together and these
words don't and what i'm getting from
what you're saying is let's imagine all
possible sequences of words and assigned
to them some number about the frequency
with which they appear and implicitly
all the rules of grammar are reflected
in those numbers that's right that's
right and this might not be the
computationally most simple way to
express a language but maybe the same
information is there
yeah so so exactly and you might ask why
like number one yes this sounds
difficult because what does it mean to
have you know probabilities attached to
all expressions ever
you know what about the expressions that
haven't been spoken yet for example um
but actually this idea comes from
um something that actually learns
grammatically correct sentences very
well just given
this input algebra and statistics and
that are the
these large language models that you see
um that are doing really well in the
world of artificial intelligence today
so
um in the world of machine learning you
can you can give you know show your
computer
a bunch of examples of correct english
text you know let it read all of reddit
or something and it just sees what goes
with what with what frequencies and you
don't need to give it any type of
grammatical input you know you don't
need to say okay dogs are nouns you know
fluffy is an adjective
you just let it see what goes with what
and you can um you know it learns some
probability distribution on text
and when you sample from that you can
see it generates coherent english text
you know you can read a blog post online
you know that discusses you know one day
robots are going to overtake the world
but that's okay because robots are
really friendly and then at the end you
realize a robot wrote it you know or
like one of these large language models
wrote it but it's sort of deceiving
because it sounds exactly like something
a human wrote it's coherent you know the
syntax is correct it's using you know
the semantics in all the right way but
it had no grammatical input all it had
was the algebraic and statistical
information
so then the question you know from the
math viewpoint is wow
somewhere
in this you know neural network
uh
structure is being learned
what is that mathematical structure if i
just have algebra and statistics what's
happening so that i can get you know
a correct reproduction of what goes with
what in my language something is in
there and
the large language models of today are
like the experiment that illustrates
that and so as a mathematician you can
look back and say wow what's really
going on under the hood like what's that
beautiful math that it's learning that
we're seeing evidence of right and so
one of the one of those things is
i guess i guess the thing for me to say
is let's continue on our exploration of
the word algebra so i get the fact that
you're combining things that makes sense
um in the world of just multiplying
numbers together there's sort of an
irreversibility right if i say 2 times 5
is 10 now that's a terrible example if i
say 2 times 6 is 12
i have 12 but i don't know how i got
there right i mean i've lost where where
they are is that
does does the algebraic point of view
assume that we can remember what we
combined to get the uh final answer
um
so so if i could try to rephrase this
question
if i have
um
some larger expression
uh maybe or like there's a meaning
attached to some larger expression maybe
we'd like to know does the algebraic
framework we're in
allow us to kind of zoom in
on whatever
individual pieces went in to make that
composite hole if i could rephrase the
question to understand it is that
exactly that's that's good yes
yes so
um i love this question
because the answer is yes and
i did actually look at your thesis
this this the answer to this actually is
really at the heart at the heart of the
thesis so
um
but it might take a little bit of time
to explain something
so okay hope the listeners are ready to
put okay so let's see one way i could
say this is
um
to explain it i have to i have to inch
out of the world of algebra just a
little bit so so the title of the thesis
is at the interface of algebra and
statistics so that kind of gives us the
feeling that we're really mingling these
two worlds
so if i if i want to talk about
something you know i have a composite
whole but how do i get information about
the little bits that go into making that
larger thing
there's a way to do this
and um
let me for a second
talk about
one way to do this that i think people
will be familiar with from the world of
probability
and that feels maybe like totally left
field but then then we'll bring it back
back and see how that relates to algebra
sounds good
so um it's just one word if i say this
word i think lots of people will be
familiar with it marginal probability
let's assume that we're not necessarily
we've heard that word before but we
can't remember what it means okay okay
so um
let's say
that
uh
i don't know you
we we're doing two things um i don't
know what they are like we're rolling
you know a die or pulling from a deck of
cards something like that
um and maybe you know you have a die in
your left hand and you have a pack of
cards in your right and you just kind of
do both and you can ask what's the
probability
that i roll
you know a three
and i pick you know a red
uh four hearts or something like that um
okay so you kind of have this joint
probability distribution that's what
it's called you have two things a die
and pack of cards you can roll or you
can draw and you have a probability for
doing both at the same time
but you might want to know well forget
the cards you know i forgot how to play
cards or i lost my deck
whatever i'm only interested in sort of
the probabilities i get for rolling my
die
that would be called marginal
probability so if you start with
knowledge of doing kind of both things
jointly
how can you take that knowledge um to
just focus in on one of those two events
you know rolling a certain number on
your die so there's a formula for that
so if you know the probability for you
know rolling each number and pulling
each card kind of together you can take
those numbers and kind of add them in
some way you can get what's called
marginal probabilities which are just
the probabilities for rolling a certain
number on your diet so you just add up
all the individual probabilities in that
set and then you get the marginal
probability exactly exactly and and
that's the key you start with something
big like two events a die in a card but
you just kind of want to zoom in on one
of those like the die so what you do
just like you said you kind of
you add over all of the possible events
that you could have had with the cards
all the cards you could have drawn so
you kind of ignore that that that
operation of adding is kind of like
forgetting you know you add all of them
up and now you have discarded that
information so in other words if i roll
you know a 4
with probability i don't know 23
let's just say um that number 23
doesn't tell me
anything about what cards i could have
drawn when i rolled the number whatever
i just said four is that what i said
okay
so that's important and and this is um
this notion of what we call marginal
probability it's like a basic thing i
guess you learn it i don't know at some
point in your intro to probability
courses so there's a formula
um and that formula again says if you
start with sort of this joint system you
can get knowledge about one of those
systems
but kind of you know at the cost of
forgetting all information losing all
access to the second one
all right now it turns out
that
if you well let me see it this way it
turns out that there's another way
to
compute marginal probability
such that you actually remember or
retain information about the deck of
cards or about that other system that
you say i don't really care about that
but rather than tossing it in the trash
trash can there's another way to compute
marginal probability that actually gives
you easy access to it you know maybe you
just toss it on your desk instead of
throwing it in the bin or something okay
okay now this um
it's essentially
uh
a passage from
i'll say sets you know i have a set of
options for the die one two three four
five six i have a set of options for the
cards there's 52 elements in that set
this is like classical probability
theory normal probability theory works
with sets but this other way that i'm
describing
which i might call
marginal probability with memory
you sort of start with your sets
but you actually move into the world of
linear algebra
so rather than sets you work with vector
spaces
and rather than probability
distributions
you work with the linear algebraic
version of a probability distribution
um now at this point i'm
i'm kind of making things more difficult
because it's like what's the linear
algebraic version of a probability
distribution is that a thing so what i
really what i really want to say and i'm
hesitant to because i'm speaking to a
physicist but what i really want to say
is the quantum version of a probability
distribution and
you know what that is i do know what
that is but go ahead but yeah i am
afraid to use the word quantum in case i
don't want people to run away in fear
too quickly
um
so what that really is just to keep it
simple you know what's the linear
algebraic version of a probability
distribution it's just a matrix let's
just think of it as a matrix of numbers
um and you might want to ask that matrix
to satisfy properties that feel like a
probability distribution for example
you might say oh i want the trace of
that matrix the sum of all entries on
the diagonal you know to add up to one
well it kind of feels like a probability
distribution probabilities add up to
once you kind of make restrictions
uh on such a matrix
um but there so there's a way to do this
when you when you do this kind of in the
the correct way
there might be more than one way to
think of a probability distribution as a
matrix or as what i was calling the
quantum version of one or technical
technical word is a density operator
folks are wondering so there might be
several ways you know to realize a
probability distribution as one of these
density operators but if you do it in
kind of what i'm thinking as
uh the correct way or
a way that is very advantageous for this
discussion
then
because now we're in the analogous world
of linear algebra you can
do
something that is completely analogous
to marginalizing
so you can actually start with a matrix
that kind of gives you information about
your joint events rolling a die and
drawing a card that information is
stored as a matrix now to marginalize
that
previously we said yeah kind of some
overall probabilities where the cards
could be whatever they wanted to be but
now i have a matrix so what's the
analogous thing of
you know that for matrices so that has a
name that's called the partial trace if
folks are wondering
so you can compute this and you get
another matrix
it's called a reduced density matrix but
it's very much just like the
linear algebraic version of a marginal
probability distribution and what's
interesting there
is that if you were to look at the
diagonal of this reduced density this
newer version of a marginal distribution
you would actually find on the diagonal
precisely the original marginal
probability distribution say of your
you're rolling your die okay that's on
the diagonal of this matrix but what
you'll also find if you
do this passage in kind of an
advantageous way
is that there are generally speaking
non-zero off-diagonal entries on that
reduced density
and those non-zero
numbers tell you
information about the deck of cards that
was there
it might say something like hey every
time uh you know you rolled a one and a
three mysteriously you also always drew
a jack or something like that
and that's what that off diagonal you
know the first and third off diagonal of
your matrix tells you sort of tells you
how many cards were in common given
these two numbers that you would roll on
your in your in your die
so that's interesting because that's the
information you don't have access to
when you marginalize in the usual way so
let me see if i got it so i mean we
certainly don't mind the word quantum
being thrown around here it's not the
first podcast
to do that uh just to be clear we're
sort of using mathematical tricks from
quantum mechanics we're not imagining
that our deck of cards or our die are
truly quantum
in any way they're pretty darn classical
we're just trying to that's right use
some tricks and so the trick is that in
conventional probability we would
imagine all the events that could happen
and we would assign a number to them the
probability and so like we'd imagine
like it's just a list of numbers and now
you're saying let's promote that from
the start
to a matrix right to instead of n
numbers an n by n array of numbers and
so there's more room for interesting
things to go on because you have both
the diagonal part of the matrix which is
your old-fashioned
set of probabilities and more info is
lurking there on the off diagonal and
this and keeping this as your storehouse
for probability information
lets you both
compute the marginal probability but
then also keep some info about what was
going on in the thing you are now
ignoring exactly that's exactly right
and is it all the info or just some of
it
yeah so so great question um
it turns out to be
all of the info really
in a way that can be made very precise
um
this kind of gets a little bit technical
though and and i have to think way back
you know into page 87 or something
um but there's a there's a way that uh
you can actually
show
that the marginals you know these things
on the diagonal
together
both of them by the way you know you can
you can marginalize out the cards or you
can marginalize out the die right okay
so you kind of have to have both of
those together with the off diagonals
is sufficient to recover the joint that
happens to be true that makes a lot more
sense to me because i thought if you
just marginalize one you're just losing
information but you're saying i'm i'm
keeping the matrix associated with
marginalizing either one yeah that's
right that makes sense okay but let's
back up and be a little bit
philosophical here i think that we've
done an admirable job of making sense so
far so let's stop doing that
um you know this this the words that you
use when you describe some of these
things you know like taking pieces and
then composing them and then
asking how to
reconstruct the whole from the parts i
mean these have
counterparts in philosophy as well as in
physics in in realms of things like uh
myriology do you know have you ever
heard the word muriology before that's
what philosophers call the relationship
between holes and parts
so how you break up a hole into parts
and i'm very interested in it because of
questions of emergence of
uh you know different higher level
descriptions from lower level
descriptions so is it and and here's an
answer i don't here's the question i
really don't know the answer to not a
leading question um is there some sense
in which these techniques you're talking
about
are helping us decide
either
the best way to take a bunch of little
things and combine them into a big thing
or
given a big thing the best way to divide
it into a set of little things um that
is a great question
uh
let's see what can i say anything
helpful about this
um
i think it would be interesting
depending on
how far
or how deep
one can explore this mathematics i think
that there'd be a very good chance
um
that the math will have something very
interesting
to offer to the philosophers with those
kinds of questions and vice versa
i think this is
exactly the real estate for that
um
but i
don't have
you know
i don't have good quotes or something
that come to mind where i can say oh
yeah you know in philosophy there's this
idea by this person and in fact we have
a theorem that says exactly what he said
but in formal terms that would be that
would be great um
but i but i do get the feeling yes that
this kind of direction you know taking
sort of a non-traditional perspective on
algebra and probability in this way
um
maybe can lead you down avenues that
haven't yet been explored so that you
can see sort of these more philosophy
philosophical questions from a different
viewpoint that maybe is more
illuminating yeah no i think i think
that's exactly right and you know like i
said i didn't know the answer to the
question when i asked you so it was not
a legal question but there's two
examples in my mind that i can't help
but just say out loud uh to give you and
the audience uh food for thought one is
i just did a podcast with anil seth who
is a neuroscientist but he also writes
papers about emergence and so he's
literally dealing with um he and his his
co-author lionel barnett um
uh time series of random variables
and they want to know you know
when
how do you coarse grain how do you like
combine different variables into a
smaller number of variables so that you
still get a predictive theory right like
what is the information you can ignore
and still be markovian in the sense that
the state now predicts the state next uh
so that's one i mean this is an open
problem it's a very very simple to state
and you know it's it's just like how do
you divide stuff up and this is very
interesting for example to people who do
origin of life
research you know what made an
individual what made a cell back then
how did you divide it up
um and the other example is i just wrote
a paper with my student uh my former
student ash mead singh called quantum
meriology so these are a word do you
know when a word is new um
how do you take a quantum system and
divide it up into
the system you care about and its
environment uh-huh so how do you take
hilbert space this big vector space and
factorize it into tensor product factors
so that one of them acts like a
classical system and the other one acts
like the environment
i have nothing wise to say other than
everything you've been talking about
sounds relevant and i should i try to
understand it better than i do
yes um i have to listen to that podcast
and read your paper now this sounds
great i've given you homework i i like
to do that but
okay so enough with the open-ended
questions let's move back to uh what you
do know something about you you bring up
um this thing called the yoneda lemma am
i pronouncing it correctly yes exactly
and it's very funny because you say like
this is on the one hand it sounds
completely trivial on the other hand
it's the most important thing in the
world uh and it it it deals very much
with this question we've been talking
about about objects and and
sub groups of objects so yeah can you
can you explain to the person on the
street with the united dilemma actually
says yes yes so the yoneda lima um is is
a very uh well-known
theorem okay it's called a lima but
really it's a theorem
in category theory
which is a modern branch of math um
that's quite abstract right so so maybe
we'll leave it there but if we want to
talk more about that heavy to say more
do we want to do we want to say what
category is for category theory is first
that's okay i was going to ask you that
at some point sure sure so um
category theory
there are i think many ways that that
one might you know say what it is or
analogies to to try to explain it um
i like to think of category theory as
a branch of math
that kind of provides a template
for other branches of math so quite
often what you'll find in mathematics is
that
ideas or constructions are kind of
repeated
over in different fields or different
branches so you might you know
build something out of legos you know in
your world maybe that's the world of
topology or something and you have your
little topological building blocks and
you construct a space i don't know i
called it lego building blocks but
whatever you construct something
and then you look at your neighbor
you know
16 blocks down in the neighborhood of
group theory and lo and behold they're
building something that looks just like
yours you know but but they call it one
thing because they live in that
cul-de-sac yeah and they have accents
over there and they have a culture and
blah blah but you call it something else
because you live in your cul-de-sac and
you call it whatever you call it and you
use your accents blah blah blah but if
you were to strip away all of those sort
of details
you know you really find that that the
two folks are doing the same thing
and category theory is kind of a common
language that mathematicians can use to
say oh here's a thing uh when you
specialize into the world of group
theory they usually call it usually call
it such and such when you specialize it
into the world of topology they give it
this name but actually both folks are
really doing the same thing so it's kind
of like a template
um where
i you kind of um i guess maybe template
another thing i like to use is another
analogy are mad libs you know these
stories where
you have uh
a basic narrative but some of the words
are missing like fill it you know
my
best blank inserted down here went to
the insert another noun you know on a
adjective day you know my friend went to
the grocery store on a lovely date or
whatever but if you substitute different
words you get a different story but the
overall narrative is is the same okay
that's very nice yeah so yeah so i like
to think of category theory is like that
kind of it's like the mad libs for
mathematics you kind of have this a
similar narrative in many mathematical
fields but depending on the words that
you choose to to fill in to that
narrative maybe you get a different
story but the overall feel is the same
so just to be i mean maybe a little bit
more concrete
i think what you mean is that there are
things like
multiplying or taking the inverse of
that appear in very very different
mathematical contexts and category
theory gives you a common
language
that's right or you know i think maybe a
more concrete example for folks because
i was very vague but you know when are
two things the same
you know if i have two sets you know two
bags of marbles are they the same
and like what does that even mean
what what considerations should i have
when i'm talking about sets what what's
interesting about a set nothing really
it's so boring there's nothing going on
it's just like dots blah blah blah what
can you say nothing all you can do is
count
how many things are in my set so if two
things are the same
well then
how do i know if two things are the same
well essentially if they have the same
number of elements in them you know if i
have two bags of marbles and they both
have 53 marbles
for all intents and purposes maybe
they're the same
but what if your set has extra structure
you know we've been talking about
multiplying things so what if i can
quote unquote multiply elements in my
set you know what if my set is the set
of real numbers i can certainly multiply
them so that's additional structure
that's there
so maybe you know you mentioned inverses
so maybe what i really have is a group
actually maybe my set was actually a
group all along but what does it mean
for two
groups to be the same
you know i have a way to multiply
elements you know each element has an
inverse
maybe i have a multiplicative identity
you know like a half times two is one so
maybe i have a thing that behaves like a
one
um so
what what should sameness mean there
well um category theory helps you make
sense of that uh and you can kind of see
when you have the answer to that what is
the proper notion of sameness it turns
out that you subsume
the notion of sameness in all of these
fields maybe in group theory it's called
a group isomorphism maybe in the world
of topology it's called a homeomorphism
you know in differential geometry you
know that has a name in each of these
fields you have different names but in
the eyes of category theory this notion
of sameness you just call it an
isomorphism got it uh so maybe when
you're an undergrad you're like oh i
have all of these vocab words to
memorize blah blah blah this is so
confusing but then category theory is
like nah it's just one concept more
category theory in high school math
that's what we need
okay and so then this good now we live
in category theory and the uni dilemma
okay so the anita lima um let me just
say what it means in english
not not the technical sense and what it
means in english i think is um can be
very relatable and you know something
that we can all maybe agree on the
oneeda lima says if you want to
understand
an object a mathematical object like a
group or a space or a set um the
neonatal limit says that all of the
information about that object
is contained
in the totality of relationships that
object has with all other objects in its
environment
um or you know a little more technical
a mathematical object is completely
determined
up to isomorphism you know by all of its
relationships so let me let me give the
give um let me say this a different way
you can learn a lot about a person by
seeing how they interact with other
people right like if you just sit
outside you know maybe
we can sit outside in coffee shops these
days and you can people watch and you
know when you see this person oh they're
like talking to the guy at the flower
shop that's cool maybe they are buying
flowers for a friend or something or you
look on social media and see who you
know such and such follows on twitter or
you know what do you do on friday nights
all of these things if you observe a
person and see how they interact with
other people you can glean a lot of
information about that person so how
does how does someone relate to other
folks of their kind
and so the point is this theorem says
the same is true
in mathematics except it's not just that
you can learn a lot
but you can learn everything everything
you need to know about a quote-unquote
mathematical person i.e an object like a
group whatever
all you not all you need to know do but
all of that information is contained in
how that object relates so what does it
mean to relate well um you know these
this gets towards
um gets to ideas like you know how do i
go from one group to another
how do i go from one vector space to
another these are things like linear
transformations or group homomorphisms
or continuous functions you know a
relationship there is really like an
arrow from your object to something else
right where that arrow is you know a
function that maybe preserves whatever
structure that's of interest in that
category that you're in
so when you say that the example
that comes to mind and i'm not sure if
i'm over interpreting or not is if i
have uh
some space some manifold or whatever um
i remember my delight when i learned
that the set of points in the space
is the same as the set of maps from one
point into the space
yes
yes
yes so is that an example or uh uh is
that the essence of the unite dilemma or
is there more richness there that i'm
not immediately perceiving
uh okay so that is intimately related to
the una dilemma um
the one dilemma
says
let's see
it says a little bit more
if you're thinking of manifolds
but suppose we were to forget all of the
structure of a manifold like okay you
have these charts look let's just think
about it you mentioned points so let's
just think of it as points for now and
kind of forget the topology in that case
i think a corollary of the one a limb or
one of them it says exactly what you
said the set of all points are the same
thing as you know functions from the one
point set into your into your set
um in that case for sets it's quite it's
like oh that's underwhelming um because
there's not that much structure and so
you might want to ask for more and so
the anita kind of gives you you need a
limit kind of gives you more in that i
totally got it you cleared up my
confusion there because what you're
saying is of course i have more than a
set i have you know a group i can
multiply things or you have some
topology or whatever and none of that is
is captured in this mapping points into
it but it is captured by its
relationships to other things exactly
exactly oh so so that's exactly what i
want to say thank you
the oneeda lima says it's not enough
just to look at functions you know from
the point into your manifold right but
because the point is a manifold it's not
a very interesting one so look at all of
the other ones yeah you know there's
like the circles and exactly all of them
so when you consider all of these other
manifolds into yours
that gives you all of the information
you need to know so it doesn't just tell
you it's cardinality you know but you
might get other you know like oh it's
smoothness or something like that okay
but now um
it
now it went from being trivial to being
um overwhelming
how in the world and do i get useful
work out of knowing that the set of
relationships between my object and
every other conceivable object uh tells
me everything there is to know about it
i mean how do i know all that what do i
do with this useful with this
information
yeah
so so i like to answer this question
back in the context of language
which we were thinking about earlier so
um there's a i mentioned you know you
were talking about philosophers and in
quotes earlier i couldn't think of one
then but here's a quote from a linguist
so not quite the same but i like this
quote which is very much like the oneeda
lemma but in the context of language
so there's a linguist john firth
i think in a 1915 1957 paper he says
you shall know a word
by the company it keeps
yeah you should know a word by the
company it keeps so like what's the
meaning of um
fire truck
well it's kind of like
all of the you know all of the context
in which the word fire truck appears in
the english language okay so fire trucks
are like maybe red i don't know
sometimes they're yellow i guess maybe
they speed quickly from from from from
all the expressions in which the word
firetruck appears you can kind of glean
information about that word but the
anita lima if we were to take the spirit
of the united lima you know borrowing
from category theory um
you kind of recover john first quote oh
everything i need to know about this
word the meaning of the word fire truck
is contained
in the network of ways that word fits
into the language right um okay and how
is this useful well it goes back to sort
of this experimental motivation we were
talking about earlier it's really
interesting
that
large language models
really only have access to the context
you know in which a word appears they
just sort of see what goes with what in
the language together with the
statistics
and somehow from that can glean semantic
information about words
how do you know that well because they
can generate coherent pieces of text you
know that look like a human wrote them
so something in there
you're using the context of a word which
both the yoneta lima and you know a
linguist like john firth might say
that's a pretty good proxy for the
meaning of that word yeah um somehow
that's being used by a machine to then
learn
something about the language
to the extent that it can produce
good text
so i think there's the usefulness it's
being used actually as we speak somehow
but then the math question is oh what
really is that okay there's the one
dilemma but if i know this algebraic and
statistical structure maybe with you
know help from category theory
one question might be oh can i model
this you know can i represent this
maybe in the precise sense of
representation theory since matrices we
talked about those those are nice to
work with um
in a way that captures captures this
information you know that's sort of
theoretically clear
sometimes neural net not sometimes but
neural networks i think are notorious
for being kind of black boxes you know
you look inside and it's like oh
180 billion parameters what is happening
something what we don't know um but
maybe you know if you take
a little bit of inspiration from
category theory maybe from quantum
physics you know linear algebra um
maybe these tools can kind of be
combined in a way that's clarifying sort
of from an interpretability perspective
but also mathematically
um so that's one long-winded way of the
usefulness i i see well let me let me
let me push on the maybe that sneak into
your sentence right there uh because
um
it's very interesting to think of uh
these deep learning models and uh
successes we've had in
language generation and things like that
and separately it's fascinating to think
about category theory and these things
you said about probabilities in quantum
mathematically inspired versions of
probabilities um
how
where are we on the
the stage from
hopeful aspiration to concrete
implementation in actually using these
mathematical ideas to help us with
building uh either not even necessarily
building understanding or doing
something with
artificial intelligence or deep learning
yeah so on this spectrum of you know
theory to actual hey can we see an
experiment you know um
maybe at this moment this day in 2021 um
i think my collaborators and i might be
we're inching towards the experimental
side of things and actually have some
stuff going um but really working on the
theory for the moment okay um
i think
maybe as
we progress um and do a good job of
explaining the ideas in a way that's
easier to understand than reading a
technical paper uh maybe that might even
encourage progress and the experimental
side even more as these ideas become
accessible
um but it's certainly in progress
absolutely okay interesting so the other
thing i want to press on is
i mean you sneaked in
what too many people would be a massive
metaphysical claim here
uh that maybe you want to defend or
maybe you're just like well let's just
see how it goes namely that
all the semantics is in the
statistics of words appearing together
like when when you say okay so red fire
truck appears a lot and red idea doesn't
appear that much and and what what
you're getting at is the idea that if we
knew all of the answers to the questions
you know how often do these combinations
appear that's all there is to know in
some sense about the language and some
people are going to say no no
when you say the word fire truck that
means something
it means something out there in the
world
so uh
i think that the the perspective that
you're sort of falling down and which is
actually one i'm quite sympathetic to is
probably something like pragmatism um
in the philosophical tradition william
james and people like that right the
meaning of a word is its use
but i do think there are other people
who would say no no the meaning is the
fire truck out there and do you care
about this distinction
right so so i'm yeah thank you for
bringing this up before i get you know
doused with fire or something
so yes i am completely aware that that
folks may say what
you can't make this claim that all some
semantic information is contained in
just the statistics you know of course i
i'm aware of this um so let me yes let
me give this caveat um
i
i acknowledge that there could be even
more mathematical in information you
know we started off by saying hey
there's algebra so cool wait a second
that's not enough there's also
statistics now i'm at this point where
i'm saying hey algebra statistics that
gives you
kind of everything
but yes maybe there could be something
else that we're not quite capturing so i
want to acknowledge that yes and that's
exciting that's great more math to be
done
however um
quite an awful lot of semantic
information is learned and i'm not um
you know making that up or saying like i
stand my ground i'm saying look out into
the world of you know language modeling
there are you know companies being built
around the success of
how much information you can learn based
on just algebra and statistics so kind
of for now you know on my mathematical
journey i'm like uh uh it's quite a lot
let me figure out this math too then um
you know down the road i'm sure there's
so much more a lot more to do but yeah
let me not um be burned at the stake for
this well no no i mean i think these are
these are controversial questions like
we don't know the answer that's why i'm
just sort of it's fun to draw these
connections but if i am you know part of
my job as podcast host is to is to be
skeptical and play the devil's advocate
so
um
if i'm
my the worries about the sort of um
language parsing
uh application of artificial
intelligence is that one that if you go
outside the domain of the training set
uh the the
a human being would understand how to
extrapolate outside whereas the computer
cannot so i tried to come up with a good
example here and i i'm not sure i i
succeeded but here's my example
um
if i put an elephant on the cardboard
airplane will it fly
ah
because the point being that you know
the language model might that's that's a
sentence no one has ever said before
right or question no one has ever asked
and the the language model might say
well airplanes fly so the answer is yes
but i said it was a cardboard airplane
with an elephant on it and the the
language model might not know that that
might make it difficult
do you have any is this a reasonable
ask for ai to be able to answer
questions like that
so
i
from a hopeful viewpoint i would like to
say yes and let me give so i love that
example i like that a lot so let me give
give you an example which i think may
show that that they're kind of thinking
or this you know this idea to generalize
beyond just sort of this data set so i'm
going to botch this so apologies to the
author of this article but i think last
year or semi-recently there was an
article in the mit technology review
about um one of these uh well-known
large language models
and and it was given a prompt you know
was asked a question i can't remember
quite exactly so i'm super paraphrasing
but it was basically like you know you
you know we're in a room
of someone's house
uh maybe in the living room and in the
dining room our friends are over there
um about to have dinner
but we we have to bring in an extra
table you know because there's lots of
people so we have a table
um
so how do we bring it from the living
room into the dining room through a
doorway like how did how are we going to
fit it okay how do we get this table to
fit through the doorway you sort of let
the the language model answer that
question so this is kind of analogous to
your question of i have an elephant on
this cardboard plane will it fly right
so it was so funny because this
large language model
i mean what would we do as a person what
would we do i have a table i want to
bring it into the other room it doesn't
fit through the door so what would we do
maybe just rotate it you know so the
legs aren't grabbing through the door or
something this language model in this
article it's like get a handsaw
and chop it in two
and then bring each piece individually
through the door
and it was funny because the
the author of the article kind of
presented this
you know to show the case look how silly
this thing is like it really can't think
like a human like how dumb but actually
it's showing you that it like learned
something about the earth you know it
learned that if you have a table and you
can cut it in half it's smaller and then
maybe then it can fit through the door
so i think that that you know that's
kind of thinking outside of the box i
wouldn't have said that if someone asked
me um so so maybe there there is a lot
in there um you know in these kind of
billions of parameters something's being
learned um but it's still kind of early
stages but examples like that make me
think oh maybe uh
maybe it can quite generalize in ways
that we we're
suspicious of no i think that's
perfectly fair i mean i i'm sympathetic
both to the worry
that uh there's a certain lack of um
uh manifest image commonsensical
view of the world that it's harder to
train the ai and therefore will get into
trouble when we ask it to leave its
domain but i'm also sympathetic to the
idea that in some sense there's no
spooky essences in the world there's
only all the relationships between
things so in principle if you could
teach
the computer all of those things it
would know everything there is to know
i'm not sure
yeah okay but i think that we have
failed to be uh sufficiently inscrutable
here i think that everything we've said
is too easy to understand so i want to
move on to
um your more recent work on
entropy because i like i like the word
entropy this is the mistake i made to
the audience i read that you had a paper
and the word entropy was in the title
and i thought that i'd be able to
understand it and that didn't happen but
that's why i have you on the podcast so
you can help me out here um
tell us how you as a mathematician think
about the word entropy and then we can
put it to work and talk about opera ads
and simplices yes yes so when i think of
the word um entropy
i really have in mind for that paper
shannon entropy
um
and so
i think there's a very easy way to sort
of think of think of it and it's kind of
the elementary way that i think of it so
if you have a probability distribution
let's just say on a finite set earlier
we talked about rolling a die for
example but you know whatever
you have some little list of
probabilities
and i think of the the entropy of that
list of probabilities or that
distribution
as sort of the
amount of surprise that's contained in
it or the amount of uncertainty so
i think um the easiest way to think of
it as the following so
if you have an event that you know for
certain is going to happen
um
you know i really love coffee and with
probability one i will have a cup every
morning when i wake up so if you know
that about me um if i tell you hey i had
coffee this morning you were absolutely
not surprised didn't learn anything yeah
it didn't learn any information so in
that it turns out when you look at the
definition of entropy the actual formula
you get a number and that number is zero
so it's like how surprised were you zero
surprised
um
so entropy is a is a number associated
to a probability distribution um and
it's zero or positive and um sort of as
you increase in that positivity it tells
you how surprised you should kind of
feel or how much information you gained
based on these if you know the
distribution on these events so i think
that's kind of the
a friendly way to think of it yeah so
just to be clear so we're back in the
world of probability distributions
and probability distributions are sets
of numbers that are all non-negative and
they add to one right that's what a
probability distribution is and so
for each probability distribution there
is an entropy that you can calculate and
it's basically is it is it safe to say
do you think of it as how spread out the
probability distribution is if it's all
peaked the entropy is low if it's all
spread out the entropy is high yeah yeah
exactly so so if you have a distribution
where basically all of the events are
the same you know probability you know
like if you have n events let's say y in
five i have five things and they all
have probability one fifth you know then
in that case they're kind of all spread
out evenly and the entropy is as high as
it can be good um and that's kind of you
have like equal amount of surprise like
oh it could have been any one of the
five and it was this one wow
um but yes if it's kind of peaked or
concentrated at at one in that sense
it's the entropy is zero no surprise you
know i had coffee this morning big deal
and so in your paper you link this uh
information theoretic notion of entropy
uh to issues in algebra and topology
which is all very cool um but maybe so i
want to get into that but i mean
is there a big picture
point that you're trying to get at what
is the goal here we've been studying
entropy ever since boltzmann and gibbs
back in the 1800s like what what is it
that we're trying to understand by
relating it to these issues in algebra
and topology yeah so um
i guess there are a couple of ways i
could answer this from a math
perspective
let me say the first one that comes to
mind
um
so entropy assigns a number to a
probability distribution um as you said
so you can kind of think of it as a
function yeah if i think of you know the
set of all probability distributions on
five elements
entropy assigns to each one of them a
number which is like the information
content of each distribution
so you might want to characterize that
function like oh i might have other
functions that go from probability
distributions to numbers are like they
all do they all convey information
content do they all have the flavor of
entropy
so so a mathematician uh might want to
look for a characterization of entropy
you know if i have a function that spits
out a number on a probability
distribution how do i know that i can
interpret that number as some type of
you know amount of information conveyed
or something that behaves like shannon
entropy are there properties that
entropy satisfies you know can i list
them is that list sufficient to tell me
you know if i walk down the street and
oh i run into another function wait let
me pull out my checklist let's see you
satisfy these properties hey you're also
entropy right you might want to know
about that um
and that's a nice organizational tool so
one thing that my paper does
gives kind of one of these
characterizations of entropy
um
but it does it by using tools from
algebra and topology and then you might
say
why would you bring in that hefty duty
stuff like we were happy over here with
just lists of numbers why in the world
go to algebra and topology
i think that's a very exciting kind of
result when you can connect fields that
do not feel related on the surface
um for me that's very exciting and
might suggest like hey there maybe
there's something deeper going on you
know we thought about entropy in this
one way but if we can look at it from a
topological perspective or an algebraic
perspective maybe that can give us new
insights or sort of new intuitions so
that was sort of another motivation for
pursuing a project like this a little a
project like this because it felt like
it connected things that shouldn't
really feel connected but there it is
the math the math is there and that's
interesting i think no that's exactly
what got me like i'm like what is i
think i thought i knew entropy why is it
being connected all these things um and
so one of the ideas i think this is
worth trying to explain which is the
idea of a simplex
um because i know what a simplex is i
took topology courses when i was in
graduate school i learned about homology
and comology and things like that and i
and you just say a probability
distribution is a simplex and i never
thought about that so
why don't you explain what is going on
there if that's possible sure sure so so
let me give a definition and actually so
i'm going to make this really easy for
everyone let's just make this a
definition so let's say
that
and
and in simplex okay so pick a number in
natural number one two three blah blah
an n simplex is
the set of all probability distributions
on
n elements
so in other words let's just think when
n is
one
i have one element
and i need a number associated to that
element that adds up to one and it's
non-negative okay well i only have one
option okay one so that's like kind of
boring you know that's my coffee
scenario i woke up this morning i had
coffee probability one
okay so let's think of n is two now
if n is two a
um
um oh
oh i think there's some okay so this is
kind of annoying um i made a little bit
of an indexing mistake um
i think technically if we were to you
know look in a textbook or wikipedia an
in simplex is a distribution on n plus
one points i think that's exactly right
and it's exactly that technicality that
was confusing but yeah okay that's okay
that's annoying okay
they'll roll with us the audience is
with us this far
okay so a zero simplex is a distribution
on one element and that's my coffee in
the morning one point okay fine
um
a one simplex
is a problem is the totality of all
probability distributions on two points
so those are you know the set of all
pairs of numbers
you know one-half one-half or whatever
um
that are non-negative
and
when you add them together you get one
so all pairs of real numbers satisfying
that
together all of those pairs are called a
one simplex and the reason by the way
that you made this uh indexing mistake
which is the most natural thing in the
world is because
on a probability distribution we know
the numbers have to add to one so if
there are n numbers you only need to
tell me n minus one of them and i know
what the other one is right that's
what's going on so if you have two
variables as soon as you give me the
probability of one of them i know the
probability in the other one right away
so i don't even need to calculate that
or whatever that's right that's right
that's exactly right yeah yeah
and that's kind of like you know if i am
thinking of thinking of a one simplex
it's usually drawn as a line yeah it's a
one-dimensional thing it's a
one-dimensional thing and that's because
if you kind of chop your line into two
bits and you know the length of the
first one
and you know both of them must add up to
one you know the length of the second
one so that's that's kind of it okay so
thank you we have this indexing thing
going on but this is exactly why i said
that's so the one simplex then is just
the list of numbers from zero to one
uh the one
simplex
um because
it can't be less than zero no no no no
negative numbers are allowed in a
probability and it can't be more than
one right yeah yeah exactly it's exact
it's yeah you can think of as the unit
interval yes which is a line that's
right um okay so in general and in an in
simplex is the set of all uh probability
distributions on n plus one elements and
so
um
you can think of it actually when you
kind of take this geometric perspective
further um it turns out that a two
simplex looks like a
triangle um a three simplex looks like a
tetrahedron and it looks like a triangle
because
you might think you need to give me
two numbers and it might be a square but
if the two numbers are too big they're
going to add to more than one right
exactly half that square is cut off yeah
exactly so half the squares cut off
exactly right yep so so when we think of
simplices we really you know you can
think of this definition i gave or you
can have the pictures in mind oh zero
simplex is a point
one simplex is a line
two simplex as a triangle and then
higher and higher you go
um
this is actually where the topology
comes in exactly right
because i have a shape you know a
triangle
i can think of that as a subset of the x
y plane you know r2 okay r2 is a
topological space i have a subspace of
that
there's my depart there's my topology um
so
actually if entropy has something to do
with probabilities and probabilities are
really simplices then the connection to
topology is maybe not too surprising
it's been right there all along yeah
all right that's the only mathematician
would say that but okay
but okay is it so let me let me get it
right um
when we are visualizing like this line
or uh the triangle or whatever
that is really the set of all
probability distributions right each
point inside is a probability
distribution exactly exactly so entropy
is a function on the simplex
yes it's a function on the simplex and
in fact
um
you can think fix a simplex you know fix
a number n maybe you have a triangle
or you have a tetrahedron or you have a
line pick one of them don't think of all
of them just pick one of those shapes
then you can
think of entropy
as a function from that one shape
into the real numbers yeah right so so
you fix the length of your
list of probabilities you know all of
those of length 13 or something that's a
12 simplex 14 simplex oh okay anyway so
you think of these numbers
and then entropy is a function on that
simplex you know valued in the reals so
really if you just wanted to have a
conversation
you know about entropy
and you kind of wanted to throw in all
probability distributions of any length
you actually have a collection of
functions each of which is called
entropy you know i have a function
out of the zero simplex
that's the entropy you know of the
the boring probability distribution one
but i also have a function out of the
one simplex that's entropy a function
out of the two simplex that's entropy
and so forth so shannon entropy really
says hey first pick a simplex first pick
you know the number in then ask for the
entropy of a point in that simplex
and you mentioned sure that the
two simplex is a little part of the
plane and therefore there's some
topology going in there but there's more
topology than that right like the no
like i said no one ever told me that a
simplex is a probability distribution or
a set of probability distributions but
they the reason why they came up is
because we were learning about topology
i think homology in particular is it is
it feasible to explain how this concept
of a simplex helps us understand the
topological structure of complicated
spaces
ah i see yes
oh
are you thinking of um
maybe
looking at a topological space
trying to under a general let's just
forget about interview for a moment a
general topological space
uh trying to understand something of
that complicated messy who knows what it
is
and then mathematicians have this
technique of kind of
imagining it's built up from little
pieces called simplices
before i answer the question is that
kind of the that is exactly it and sort
of figuring out how many holes there are
and how many donuts etc yes yes yes yes
okay right so this gets into the ideas
of homologying and co homology okay so
so this is exactly right um you may uh
okay so topology
i think for for viewers we've used it
several several times now so maybe folks
know what it is but i like to think of
it as like this squishy version of
geometry you know to a topologist a
circle and a triangle is the same thing
because if a triangle is made out of a
wet noodle and you kind of squish in the
corners you can get a circle so in
topology this kind of squishiness is
allowed
but if that's allowed then like what are
we doing you know this kind of goes back
to the idea of when are two things the
same which we talked about in category
theory a while ago like when are two
topological spaces the same or not
and one
thing that you
you can use
to kind of distinguish spaces is by
counting how many kind of fundamental
holes do they have you know a circle and
a triangle are kind of the same you can
see that and they have
you know holes if i if i hold a little
key ring you know i can stick my finger
through it that's kind of the hole
um but not all topological spaces can we
see with our real you know with our eyes
you know i ca not there are other spaces
that aren't key rings you know they're
very abstract and they're in some
textbook buried deep in the pages and
how can i understand that object you
know i can only visualize it kind of in
my mind based on some equations or
something and i can't really hold it in
my hands but how can i still investigate
it and this is where simplicities are
very helpful
you can imagine
imagine
kind of probing your space
with maybe simplicity so for example
think of just the surface of something
like a doughnut or you know a taurus
maybe i can think of kind of
triangulating that surface you know
maybe thinking of the entire exterior of
a donut is very difficult but if i kind
of imagine like a triangular shaped grid
i can maybe kind of understand something
about the little pieces
yeah sorry so in other words
um if you have some wiggly thing
uh topological space of whatever number
of dimensions in principle a wiggly
thing requires an infinite amount of
information to specify yes but if we
just chunk it up if we tessellate it we
can keep the topology the same while
reducing that informative information to
a finite number of sort of what what
triangle is connected to what or what
you know what tetrahedron is connected
to what exactly exactly it's a finite
number of thing things and it's also a
combinatorial thing you know oh a two
simplex has all these many edges and
then it's connected to this thing with
these many edges and maybe there are
some intersections or something so
you've taken something that's kind of
complicated
and yeah wiggly and just what do i do
with this but if you can break it up
into smaller pieces that are maybe bite
size easier to handle maybe
combinatorials you can start to kind of
count things
that makes it more manageable
um and then
yeah then there's this this leap you
know you have to bring in some kind of
tools to make sense of what you mean by
a whole like i know what that means in a
key ring but what if i have some
abstract space like what is a
mathematician's definition of of a hole
in a topological space
and what if i am in you know 17
dimensions how in the world do i make
sense of that and that's kind of where
these simplicial tools are very useful
to answer these kind of questions
yes and
somehow this is going to connect to
derivations and upper ads and then i i
can try to find a thread that gets us
there but i think that would be dumb
when i could just ask you to do it for
us
yeah so let me
give
the
light version l-i-t-e
and then uh depending on we can decide
how which directions we want to go we
can get deeper
but let me yeah there are a lot of words
oh
simplices derivations algebra what's
happening
okay so here's the here's the easiest
way that i can say this think let's
think back to shannon entropy entropy
okay the amount of kind of surprised or
information contained in a probability
distribution
it turns out and it's not too it's not
hard at all to show that entropy
fits into a formula
that looks
eerily similar to something you might
see
in different places across the
mathematical landscape
and that formula
kind of hints that entropy behaves like
a derivation what's a derivation
um we'll think back to calculus
um and the leibnitz rule from calculus
the problem we all learned this a long
time ago if i have two functions
f and g what's the derivative of f times
g
you know and then we all learn about
this product rule oh it's the derivative
of f times g
plus f times the derivative of g
okay the leibniz rule well it turns out
that entropy satisfies an equation that
looks very much like this
but kind of not really but you can see
this formula and you think to yourself
oh something's going on so in a so long
story short
my paper is taking that kind of
intuitive
something's going on here and making it
very precise
and saying there is a very precise way
in which entropy
satisfies
the leibniz role
and moreover
time you have
a function in a certain context i have
to be very precise that satisfies the
leibniz rule it's basically entropy you
know maybe a constant multiple or
something good yeah this is the kind of
thing that gets mathematicians very
excited where they show that something
is something else yeah exactly exactly
and is this related to that was a very
nice light derivation good or uh
explanation um
one of the elements that comes in here
that i think is
graspable is the idea that the boundary
of a boundary is zero right this very
famous deep topological fact like if you
take a disc its boundary is a circle but
there the circle doesn't have any
boundary uh it's boundaryless and the
way that
a fancy differential topologist would
express that is as d squared equals zero
where this d is is the boundary operator
so
am i reading too much into the letter d
or
or is this relating d to a derivative
and therefore now to entropy
so
um at the moment
uh
we both might be reading too much into
it so so in the paper i unfortunately do
not have the opportunity to say that the
d that you see there
if you apply it twice you get zero i
think though that would be very exciting
um and i think that a paper like this
suggests that it should be investigated
more for this very reason
um because there is a precise sense in
which you think about you know
derivatives in the sense of calculus um
derivations and these boundary operators
you know things that satisfy d squared
equals zero um go hand in hand um this
if folks want to look up something they
can look up the rom co homology since we
were talking about chromology earlier
and see that these ideas are mixing
together very intimately and beautifully
in a nice way
now i didn't get so far there i didn't
get to that that point yet um but i
think that it suggests that there's
something deeper to look in that
direction
there have been other results in the
past few years by other mathematicians
involving other characterizations of
entropy
that also swirl around this d squared
equals zero idea
i think that that's very peculiar i mean
i'm talking in the last you know four or
five years or so
so the fact that um entropy is kind of
coming up in these topological and
algebraic
areas you know independently
might suggest that there is indeed
something going on there
um
yeah and is it possible that there's
some sort of duality relationship
because in the word of in the world of
homology and co-homology our audience
knows what neither one of these words
mean but the idea is that these are two
different ways of topologically
characterizing spaces
um
one of which sort of looks at the
structure of spaces and the other one
looks at the functions you can put on
spaces and it turns out that these very
different sounding words are in fact
sort of mirror images of each other in
some particular way and i'm wondering if
maybe
that is what is going on with entropy
versus um
uh
i'm not sure what entropy would be dual
too but but somehow these these
simplicial structures i don't know
yeah so i would say that this is
very active research
and something i am thinking about daily
these days so maybe come back in a year
and i'll have really great answers for
that but that's exactly uh where i'm
headed next yes and it's only possible
because of the psychological difference
between physicists and mathematicians
because you know the physicists will say
well look what do you mean entropy it's
not it's a number like you give me a
distribution i give you a number and
there's really nothing more to say
but the mathematician will say you know
with like with the with the boundary
operation
um
the boundary of an n dimensional thing
is an n minus one dimensional thing and
so the physicist just stops there but
the mathematician says let's consider
the combination of all n-dimensional
things and n minus one-dimensional
things and n minus two-dimensional
things as like one giant thing and the
physicist said you've lost me you're
like you've gone crazy but when you make
that leap you're now able to
invent operators and relationships and
things like that and maybe discovered
things about entropy 150 years later
that the physicist never found out yes
yes that's exactly right and um this
reminds me a little bit of kind of the
flavor of the paper that i wrote i
mentioned that there is a there is a you
know a formula or an equation that
entropy satisfies that kind of got me
into the project oh that that looks kind
of like a derivation can we make that
precise what's interesting
is that the paper kind of develops a
more general framework
for which that equation is a special
case ah good
so it kind of says yeah that's just the
shadow of something much richer going on
there's something kind of hovering
overhead you know above head for which
that one equation that we kind of all
know you know we see in our favorite
information theory textbook or something
it's just an example
of something
richer maybe that's going on that's
pulling from these tools that maybe you
didn't know they were there like just
look up oh they're floating on the
ceiling or something oh we just didn't
know um so so i think
yeah
it might feel complicated to say wait a
second we started with probability
distributions on n things and now you're
like consider n minus one and n minus
two and then
maps between them and d squared equals
zero what but actually when you when you
kind of do all this it might seem
um you know like heavy lifting at first
but then you're quite rewarded at the
end because it kind of gives you a
different vantage
point for which a lot of things may fall
out nicely at the end and i can't think
of a better place to end our
conversation and exactly that hoping
that everything falls out nicely from
the end so
ty janet bradley thanks so much for
being on the windscape podcast thank you
sean it was great to be here
[Music]
you